so the Florida Department of Education
recently decided to ban AP
African-American history now AP is
relevant here that means advanced
placement these are not only elective
courses but they are above and beyond
that courses that depending on whether
you take the AP test can actually go
towards college credit and optional
elective and a very small percentage of
students take these courses and the
reason that Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis is now giving for the reason
that this class has been banned is
completely and totally absurd the
department says that the class was
teaching students activism
intersectionality encouraging the war
encouraging ending the war on black
Trans queer and gender non-conforming
and intersex people that it's queer
Theory and that it is indoctrination now
again this is not a mandatory class
that's being pushed on anybody it's an
elective class that students can choose
to take if this is subject matter they
are interested in and they are issues
that should be determined
from within the community not by Ron
DeSantis in terms of what is taught
DeSantis was asked about it during a
press conference and uh here is what he
had to say
that move people saying you know this is
exactly what we're appearing with the
individual Freedom bill I don't know if
you or the commissioner could maybe
expand a little bit more about sure I
mean I think so
um you know as you know in the State of
Florida our education standards not only
don't prevent but they require teaching
black history all the important things
that's part of our Core Curriculum this
was a separate course on top of that for
advanced placement credit and the issue
is we have guidance so he admits that
that's interesting we're going to get
back to that lines and standards in
Florida we want education not
indoctrination if you fall on the side
of indoctrination well we're going to
decline if it's education then we will
do this course so when I heard it didn't
meet the standards I figured yeah they
may be doing here it's way more than
that this course on black history what
are one what's one of the lessons about
okay queer Theory now who would say that
an important part of black history
queer theory that is somebody pushing an
agenda on our kids and so when you look
to see they have stuff about
intersectionality abolishing prisons
that's a political agenda and so we're
on that's the wrong side of the line for
Florida standards we believe in teaching
kids uh facts and how to think but we
don't believe they should have an agenda
imposed on them when you try to use
black history to shoehorn in queer
Theory uh you are clearly trying to use
that for political purposes so there's a
couple different things that are
important to talk about here first of
all I don't know me David pakman I don't
know whether queer first of all I don't
know whether queer theory is part of
that course but let's imagine that it is
I don't know whether it's correct
to have a part of a course about black
history include queer Theory I don't
know whether that's appropriate or not I
don't think Ron DeSantis knows either
he's not an expert on black history and
neither am I so the idea that if that is
the case that that is part of the
subject matter then the course is bad or
wrong doesn't make a lot of sense to me
that's first and foremost but again this
is an elective Associated Associated
Press AP Advance placement course okay
these are in a sense College equivalency
courses when I took AP economics for
example in high school I got college
credit for that course in college it
would be completely normal to have more
Niche classes of this style and it would
make sense that the AP black history
course would differ from whatever is
taught to every high school student but
what DeSantis and other people in
Florida are doing it's sort of slick in
a sense they want to act as though
seven-year-olds are being taught queer
theory for example or that prisons
should be abolished even if it's true
that those things are in that course
this is not being taught to first and
second graders this is an elective
College equivalency advanced placement
class but they don't want to let the
students make their own decisions
remember nobody's going to be forced
into this course students in
consultation with guidance counselors
their parents whoever can decide based
on their interests whether this is a
course that they want to take he's
removing the choice
and proactively saying we're going to
get government involved to ban a class
this is part of the decidedly anti-lgbt
Bent by the way that Ron DeSantis has
been on and it's been extra clear lately
just a few days ago uh DeSantis
requested information from from
University Statewide of every student
who has
um I forget the exact wording but
basically it's like a list of trans
students which as we've said in other
states Texas tried this it doesn't
appear that that's actually legal so
DeSantis is making his intentions very
clear even though he claims to be small
government government shouldn't do
something unless absolutely necessary it
is not necessary to get involved in
Banning this optional advanced placement
class and that's what he's doing and
instead of promoting education and
promoting understanding and promoting
Choice hey there there's things
available to you you can choose what it
is that you want to study particularly
if you're looking at AP classes it's
instead censorship and it is ignorance
and it's all of those things so the
class should be reinstated nobody should
be forced to take it it is an optional
AP class it might have been 12 students
who were going to take this thing but
they don't care it's pathetic and it's
very clear that this is again people
like DeSantis loves to love to say the
left is virtue signaling coming out
against this class and trying to ban it
and pretending like it's being forced on
children uh is exactly the type of
virtue signaling they claim to be
against there was a March for Life
and this is an anti-abortion event
former NFL coach Tony Dungy who I didn't
realize was a sort of right-wing
extremist he spoke at the March for Life
and he drew a parallel between NFL
football player Demar Hamlin's cardiac
arrest and abortion what is the
connection I sure as hell don't know but
let's see if we can understand it as
Tony Dungy explains it
well those prayers were answered
tomorrow's recovering now he's home he's
been released from the hospital
but what's the lesson in that
you know an unbelievable thing happened
that night a professional football game
with millions of dollars of ticket money
and advertising money on the line that
game was canceled why
because a life was at stake and people
wanted to see that life saved
even people who aren't necessarily
religious got together and called on God
well that should be encouraging to us
because that's exactly why we're here
today
wait a second
because every day in this country
innocent lives are at stake the only
difference is they don't belong to a
famous athlete and they're not seen on
national TV but those lives are still
important to God and in God's eyes
so I did not realize that Tony Dungy had
these views and there are a couple
important things I think to mention here
you can be individually
pro-life or pro-choice you know for
abortion against abortion in some cases
or not whatever right I mean it is your
choice when we say pro-choice
I'm certainly not saying pro-choice
means everyone must be in favor of
abortion being safe available and legal
I'm saying it should be everyone's
choice if you or Tony Dungy or whoever
is opposed to abortion
then I don't think anyone should force
you or a mother or whoever to have an
abortion that's what I when I say choice
I mean choice on both sides but when
they liken abortion to the Damar Hamlin
situation which by the way it's such a
stretch it doesn't even make any sense
whatsoever
you are starting to go over into this
extremely authoritarian perspective
which is it's no one's true well it's
Tony dungy's choice that no one else be
able to decide for themselves what the
right decision is there are people who
can choose not to get an abortion for
whatever reason they want that's part of
the choice but they want to take Choice
away from everybody they want to take
bodily autonomy away from women and
families in consultation with whoever
they want to consult with if you as a
pregnant woman
want to consult with your clergy about
what you should do that's your choice
and that's fine that's part of the
choice we're talking about but to say
that the woman should not even have on
the table the choice to say well what's
right for me is an abortion that is
where these people go completely haywire
and by the way against their own
principles of keep government out of
stuff to the extent that we can one
other thing the stick to sports crowd is
very silent very very silent the shut up
and dribble LeBron people are very very
quiet when it comes to someone like Tony
Dungy expressing an anti-abortion view
which is just part of course of that
hypocrisy that they have
anti-vaccine so-called expert Sherry
Tenpenny is again spreading fear and
promulgating disinformation about the
covid-19 vaccine she is now warning
everyone that is close to you is soon
going to die from the covid vaccine
not from covid from the covid vaccine
Sherry Tenpenny is now warning about a
tsunami of deaths in 2023 she says by
the end of this calendar year the Year
of the Lord 2023 every one of us will
know five maybe ten or more people who
have died from the covid vaccine Okay
let's listen to what she had to say this
is very instructive in terms of
fear-mongering and so many other things
let's listen now we're seeing the
tsunami of deaths and I've been talking
about since the beginning of 21 millions
of people are going to die you know when
Judy mikovitz came out on pandemic at
the beginning of that and by the way
that was one of the biggest nonsense
propaganda films uh pandemic and
mikovitz it's it's crazy to even mention
it and then
that more than 50 million people are
going to die and everybody was like whoa
and when they started interviewing me
and I and asked me what did I think
about that number I said it's way too
low oh it's going to be much more than
50 million people in America alone
and we're already starting to see it
we're not
so the tsunami of deaths is coming it's
already here and I believe that what's
happening now and is is starting to
happen now is the tsunami of regret
of the people that fell for the lies
for your friends and family members and
parents and children and all they did to
your grandchildren just could not be
told otherwise but now that people are
dying like flies I mean my business
partner has 83 close people in his life
that have died
you know most people the truth is most
people don't have 83 people in their
lives that they are close to this this
is like a separate issue but these are
obvious lies 83 yeah no it's the
beginning
and I predict that by the end of this
year every person in this room and every
person listening behind here is going to
know a minimum of five probably ten or
more close friends and family you don't
have as many friends as her business
partner so you'll have only five to ten
people die members that have died from
these shots right
so I want to remind everybody and this
is so controversial every time people
say David is Sherry 10 penny a doctor is
she not a doctor and and when I explain
it people get mad Sherry Tenpenny is not
a medical doctor she is an osteopathic
physician now whenever I make that
distinction people start writing in
including osteopaths saying David you
shouldn't act as though that is less
than being an MD I'm not saying anything
I'm just telling you she's not an MD
she's an osteopathic physician and her
claims of no scientific basis it doesn't
mean every osteopath believes the things
Sherry 10 Penny believes I'm not saying
that at all all I'm telling you is
actual medical doctors have debunked her
claims health organizations have
debunked her claims many osteopaths have
also debunked her claims but in the
sense that osteopathic Physicians are
doctors she is indeed a doctor now if
she sounds familiar and this is really
the big point I want to make it's
because we have listened to her
predictions in the past and of course
none of them have come to pass what I
would like is accountability for these
people when they make these predictions
let's remember and then we can follow up
and say hey that stuff didn't happen
because remember when she said this last
year the more shots you get the more the
more you destroy your immune system and
the faster that happens and it's
anticipated the German data says
that by the end of 2022
every fully vaccinated person over the
age of 30 may have the equivalent of
full-blown
vaccine-induced immune suppressed AIDS
ladies and gentlemen as a fully
vaccinated person over the age of 30 I
am here today to tell you I do not have
full-blown vaccine induced immune
suppressed AIDS I do have a little neck
pain from a weird movement I did at the
gym three days ago but I don't have
full-blown AIDS so the point is it's
fear fear fear and we're going to talk
about this later I can't believe I'm
saying these words but later on in the
show I'm going to talk to you about
Tucker Carlson fear-mongering about his
space vagina I know it sounds insane but
it's what it is
um they have to induce fear
fear generates the environment they need
in order to then sell you something
whether it's tickets to an event or a
product or liquid liquid silver whatever
it is they sell you and then there's no
follow-up and there's no accountability
we have to hold these people accountable
for their endless failed predictions
this is yet another one of those and if
you want us if you're listening today
and you want to see what this looks like
when this woman makes these claims we'll
have all of these clips on our YouTube
channel youtube.com the davidpackman
show and on our Instagram which you can
find by searching Instagram for David
Pacman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
remember that the David packman show
quite literally depends on your support
primarily through the membership program
which you can sign up for at
joinpakman.com we do an extra show every
day for our members and I would love to
see you in the audience of that world
famous bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com I want to talk to you
today about the continued Scandal
surrounding lying Republican Congressman
George Santos and what is now it's not
even really an alleged past as a drag
queen and I know that the term Queen is
it appropriate is it not I I don't
really know now before I dive into the
topic I want to start with I don't care
about drag queens in the sense that I
don't believe drag queens are a danger
to children I don't believe drag queens
are a prominent or important political
social cultural or economic issue to be
describing or talking about I just to me
drag queens are a non-issue Republicans
have made drag queens an issue claiming
some of the things I just said I don't
believe claiming as Republicans have
that putting together children and drag
queens is dangerous to the children in
some way
um working to get drag queen story hours
of different kinds where men dressed in
drag read stories to kids
they have made it a political issue and
have claimed that there is a fundamental
immorality to drag queens and now it
turns out that lying Republican
Congressman George Santos regularly
dressed in drag now I don't know if
there is a pejorative connotation to
saying drag queen I don't know if
there's a difference between dressing in
drag regularly and being a quote drag
queen I don't know the difference but it
seems to me that George Santos was a
drag queen for a period of Time Business
Insider now reports George Santos
partied in drag over a three-year period
new videos appear to show despite his
suggestion it was a one-off I want you
to remember
he initially said it's not him in the
pictures when these pictures came out of
Santos reportedly dressed in drag it's
not me more recently he said
it's me I did it once I had fun so sue
me but now videos and photos spanning a
three-year period 2005 to 2008 appear to
show Santos in a drag Persona he went by
the name Katara so we are now we've got
George Santos we have Anthony devolder
now we have Katara which was his drag
character George Anthony Katara Santos
de volder
um they have been fear-mongering against
the LGBT community they have been
fear-mongering about drag queens and now
it turns out that one of their own who
they are very hesitant to just condemn
and say this guy is such a liar he
shouldn't resign he just he should
resign members of Congress have not been
doing that in any significant numbers
they now are saying nothing about it and
the story first broke last week when
freelance journalist Marissa kabus
published a sub-stack post about the
drag queen past of George Santos and it
included the pictures and testimony of
friends and all of it and even in the
follow-up of this story George Santos
continued to lie first saying it wasn't
him then saying he did it once and then
now we have evidence that he was
regularly dressing in drag I don't care
that George Santos dressed in drag I
don't care what I care about is he lies
about everything everything and of
course the selective outrage from
Republicans about if and when he's doing
the right thing or the wrong thing
versus when it's Democrats is
disappointing it's disgusting and it's
pathetic so yeah I'm disappointed that
there are more lies but it's also
important to call out their hypocrisy
and I still am increasingly convinced
that Santos is going to be able to just
stick this out and eventually media is
going to move on but the stories
continue to come and I've got to talk
about a crazy one next
um
I don't I don't even know how to
introduce this
George Santos says he survived an
assassination attempt
that is the latest Rachel Maddow has
surfaced video of an interview that
George Santos gave in Portuguese okay so
the clip we're going to look at is in
Portuguese with subtitles and I'll pause
momentarily you know brief every once in
a while to tell you what's being said
he claims he was the victim of an
attempted murder that he survived and it
led to him being under police protection
there is no evidence of this I should
mention listen to this so at the top of
the show I went through a long but
definitely not exhaustive list of the
known lies of freshman Republican
Congressman George Santos of New York uh
you're probably familiar with some of
the greatest hits by now the volleyball
star and Wall Street fortune and all
that stuff right but here's something
you have not heard before did you know
that Congressman George Santos also
claims he was the target of an
assassination attempt which required him
being put under official police
protection wow that is what George
Santos claimed last month in an
interview with a Brazilian podcast the
podcast is called radio novello a
presenta give my pronunciation radio
novello a presenta they shared this
video from the interview exclusively
with us so you won't see this anywhere
else but I want you to see it in this
interview then Congressman elect George
Santos is speaking with the hosts in
Portuguese so we have subtitled it he
starts off talking about an alleged Act
of vandalism which he says was targeted
at him simply because he's a Republican
but then in the midst of that he says oh
also someone tried to murder him
um
[Music]
so he says this happened in Florida at a
near after New Year's Eve parties
so he says the vandalism was because he
was at a Republican party
um
okay so there he casually mentions I
already suffered an assassination
attempt which I survived
yeah very very casual we had police
protection etc etc we have already
suffered an attempt on my life an
assassination attempt yeah
there was an assassination attempt
really
um then Congressman elect George Santos
did not elaborate on his claim in the
interview We Have Tonight reached out to
Congressman Santos's office
to get more information about him saying
that he was the victim of an attempted
murder yeah um getting New York police
protection at his home as a result there
ought to be a record of that sort of
thing if it happened we've inquired
about this claim from him we have not
heard back we do live in Hope Mr Santos
did offer more detail about a different
act of violence he says was committed
against him in this interview with the
same Brazilian podcast he said he was
the victim of a very very very
Brazen mugging in the middle of the day
in the middle of New York one of one of
New York City's busiest thoroughfares
very logical
[Music]
oh my God he says oh God so first of all
he says this was at Fifth and 55th okay
I don't understand how any such mugging
could take place at 5th and 55th in the
middle of the day he volunteers before
asking me any questions they weren't
black they were even white but they
still even white people these weren't
even black folks and and they still had
the audacity to Rob him in broad
daylight
they took his watch yeah and his shoes
in the middle of the day on Fifth and
55th which is
yeah okay so I don't know that any of
these things are true but these are
extraordinary claims and it appears as
though the lies simply will not stop
voters are now furious with this guy he
claims I'm not hearing from anybody who
wants me to resign let's talk about that
next Camilla deshaylis or D shalu I'm
not exactly sure the pronunciation is a
congressional reporter at the Washington
Post she did a great thing where she
spoke to a bunch of residents in George
Santos's District who voted for him and
here is what some of them had to say
about whether they want Santos to go do
you feel like regret for voting for him
yes of course
because he's dishonest and he has no
experience I am outraged right
the idea that he
should remain in office
ludicrous when you voted for him what
was your initial like why you wanted to
vote for him oh he seemed to be you know
somebody who gave a damn about this
neighborhood they cared about people in
general so they thought that he really
was going to make some kind of petitions
right I just wish
he shouldn't be an office yeah so
um Santos in insists that none of the
people that voted for him want him to
resign but it seems that they do and I
continue to be disturbed by the ease
with which none of this stuff surfaced
before the election and you know again
I'm not necessarily pointing fingers but
opposition research didn't turn it up
and um journalistic work didn't turn it
up it seems like if you go to get a job
at a cell phone store you were vetted
more thoroughly ultimately than than how
George Santos was vetted now this news
spoke to high schoolers from his
district who will be able able to vote
in the next election here's what they
had to say
Schreiber High School in Long Island's
Nassau County
heart of Representative Santos's third
congressional district
I mean I think he's an embarrassment and
a pathological liar true we sit down
with a group of AP U.S history students
at Schreiber high they are 16 and 17
which means they will all be old enough
to vote in 2024. how many of you would
register as an independent if you
registered today
not many of you would register as a
Democrat all but two how many of you
would register as a republican two of
them
their history teacher estimates
republican-leaning students are
outnumbered by Democratic leaning
students by an almost two to one margin
at the school but I haven't found one
kid who is sympathetic to George Santos
they know the importance of the numbers
in the House of Representatives and
although Santos represents them for
issues that they agree on
they don't have sympathy towards men 16
year old Taj parekh is one of the future
Democrats I think it's it's a very scary
situation for us having someone who is
so clearly lied and so clearly fabricate
his entire resume uh representing all of
us
sixteen-year-old Nathan Jackman is one
of the future Republicans I like how the
Nassau GOP came out against him but
obviously Kevin McCarthy should come out
against him true and they should have a
vote on the house floor in order to
expel put every single member of
Congress on the record I want the liar
to stay or I want the liar to go
um we this guy's got to go and I every
day that goes by that he remains in
office I worry that he is going to be
able to stay if you want to check out
these clips I've played we'll have them
all on our Instagram which you can find
by searching Instagram for David packman
show we're going to take a quick break
what a program we have for you today
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show some of
you may remember that Donald Trump is
being sued by author e Gene Carroll for
defamation and for sexual assault and
this is all related to an alleged
encounter in the 1990s
truth is sometimes Stranger Than Fiction
we have now learned that Donald Trump
mistook an image
of e Gene Carroll for his own ex-wife
Marla Maples in a deposition that took
place at Mar-A-Lago last year now what
you know Trump has argued I wouldn't
have sexually assaulted Jean e Gene
Carroll because she's not my type
now a lot of people might react and say
I don't sexually assault people so it
doesn't matter what the woman looks like
because I don't sexually assault people
no okay fine Trump said I wouldn't have
done it because she's not my type fine
so the fact that he thought it was his
ex-wife suggests maybe she actually is
his type it's unbelievable there's a
Washington Post article by Shayna Jacobs
Trump thought photo of accuser was of
ex-wife during deposition
Donald Trump mistook his sexual assault
accuser e Gene Carroll for his ex-wife
Marla Maples when shown a photograph
from the 1990s in a deposition at
Mar-A-Lago last year potentially
undermining one of the common defenses
he has used to deny an attack Trump
who's being sued by Carol for defamation
and sexual assault stemming from the
same alleged encounter has repeatedly
said Carol is not his type suggesting an
assault could not have occurred because
he would not have pursued her
romantically that's Marla yeah that's my
wife Trump said when he was examined by
Carol's lawyer Roberta Kaplan in a new
selection of excerpts from the
deposition that was unsealed Trump's
blunder in a sworn deposition was
quickly corrected by his attorney Alina
Haba who told him it was Carol not
Maples Maples was Trump's second of
three wives trumpet did not immediately
have a comment the black and white photo
at issue has been circulating since
Carol made the allegations detailing an
account in her Memoir of a forced sexual
act Trump has denied ever knowing her
said she's not my type okay we all know
that this is a a stunning situation and
it if if this didn't deal with things as
serious as sexual assault we could all
just be laughing at it but one of the
ways that Trump has tried to dismiss
these allegations and dismiss and
undermine The credibility of EG and
Carol has been to say she's simply not
my type I'm not attracted to her I
wouldn't have been attracted to her in
the 90s he's basically saying she is not
desirable enough for me to even pursue
her never mind force myself upon her or
something like that
here we learn oh
an image of her in the 90s Trump
actually believed was his own ex-wife
someone who I would assume Trump was
romantically and sexually interested in
now the bigger problem of course is that
this entire line of reasoning
perpetuates some really horrible
societal stereotypes about women and
sexual assault and it when Trump
mistakes his accuser for his ex-wife it
not only continues to go along that line
which is like was she attractive enough
for Trump to sexually assault her or not
right which is like a crazy conversation
to be having but it also more generally
raises questions about whether anything
Trump says can be believed whether any
of Trump's defenses can be believed when
they might be based on complete
misapprehensions by Donald Trump
altogether
this is not the first time Trump has
been accused of sexual assault he has a
history of denying allegations
undermining The credibility with similar
statements not my type wouldn't have
done it that sort of thing I don't know
whether this is going to go anywhere but
Trump mistaking the accuser for his own
ex-wife is really wild wild stuff
Christian nationalism is something we've
spoken about a lot on the program
Christian nationalism is very generally
speaking of you where you believe that
Christianity should be not only one of
many religions that people in their
private lives can choose to follow but
directly connected to the law of the
land and civil government Christian
nationalism includes the idea that the
doctrine of Christianity should be first
and foremost and in the Forefront of
what determines what are our civil laws
and civil government now congresswoman
Lauren bobert from Colorado who recently
just barely barely barely won
re-election she recently made some
comments about Jesus and Christianity
and it's really the stuff of nightmares
she spoke about the end times and the
Rapture and let's look at the clip first
but I I want you to just have in mind
and I know I've said this before and
people get offended what is the line
between religion and delusional mental
illness
when it comes to the sorts of stuff she
talks about I don't pretend to know the
answer but let's listen to what she said
and uh one thing that I love uh just an
analogy maybe maybe it's true or maybe
it's not about the second coming of
Jesus I've heard stories of you know
people believing that Christians are
going to be
um hiding out in caves and you know and
just um lockdown maybe maybe it's a
lockdown maybe it's a government
lockdown but they're shut in and they
beg for Jesus to come back he comes back
and rescues them I don't think that
that's the way it's going to be
if if the Old Testament is a type and a
shadow of the New Testament and you look
at the Exodus from Egypt Pharaoh he was
the one who called
for God to get his people he said get
your people out of here and I believe if
if that type and Shadow is true for the
New Testament the church God's people
will be out in such a great horse that
Satan himself will call for the second
coming of Jesus who say I cannot do a
thing in this Earth with your people
here you come and get them
come on Wow incredibly powerful stuff
now I really need you to understand what
she's talking about here this you know
second coming of Jesus stuff
Resurrection Rapture end times this is
all you know there's different flavors
and I know no matter which summary I
give someone will write in and say David
you're misunderstanding this or that
aspect of it remember there's a thousand
versions of this but it is some
combination of there is going to be some
kind of end time event
where the Christians that are alive and
the resurrected Believers are going to
rise in the clouds and here on Earth bad
things are going to happen in some of
these versions all of the Jews die and
some of these virgin virgins versions
000 Jews survive there's every
everything under the sun
it's all pretty Bonkers okay for from
just an Earthly perspective and it is
apparently in some circles not only
acceptable but welcomed to hear elected
officials talking in this way and they
use these beliefs to inform
um what they believe the law should be
for example the very same place that
Lauren bobert gets the ideas you just
heard she gets her ideas about abortion
which then she uses to say here's what
the law should be even though we're
supposed to have separation of church
and state so comments like these are
just completely appalling and her desire
to inject this sort of stuff into civil
government is an obvious violation of
the separation of church and state it if
if if she got her way it would lead to
unofficial discrimination and
marginalization of non-christians of
non-religious people altogether and it
is one of the scariest things that is
going on right now as a movement within
the Republican party yeah Maga stuff
it's wacky it's scary space lasers all
of it right it's crazy but the Christian
nationalism stuff is particularly
dangerous here's another clip from the
same interview this was the faith in
action podcast I guess Lauren bobert
says God tells her re-election would be
like the Prophet Elijah in the Bible
defeating the prophets of all this is
what this is what God said to her I
don't know if this was like at a cafe at
a bar or in private prayer wow totally
um
can do that they called him a
conservative right um just allowed him
to Define himself is that it's bizarre
um but I won again with 51 of the vote
barely I just took a lot longer to get
there but you know throughout all of
this um I was telling you you know God
was really pressing on my heart the
story of Elijah okay she's saying God
spoke to her okay I really need
everybody to understand she is saying
that a man in the sky I think they still
say he's a man of sorts or a masculine
entity in the sky
spoke to her about specific passages
in the context of her re-election he
said the true God will answer by fire
and those who worshiped
oh I said ball I guess it's bail the
true God he said Elijah said prove it if
Baal is the true God tell him to answer
by fire and they're calling him for him
they're screaming they're hollering
they're cutting themselves or acting a
pool uh you know we've seen that like in
2020 riots and stuff right but
their God didn't show up Elijah was
mocking them yeah well maybe cry a
little bit louder maybe he can't hear
you maybe he's sleeping maybe he's on
vacation I love that so much
um and then he went he said you know
what I'm gonna do you one better I don't
want you to say that this is some kind
of fluke um some sort of combustion that
just happened I'm gonna drench the altar
with fire or with water three times fire
or water whichever three times he went
and drenched the altar with fire and God
with water and God still showed up by
fire and that's what he was showing me
with this election he said it may look
impossible in the natural that there
will not be a victory you may hear the
voices you may hear other people but I
am going to show up now of course these
are always stories that are that are
told with the hindsight of knowing how
the election turned up she barely won
and and she could have lost would she
still be telling the story listen God
came to me and he said your re-election
is going to be like when Prophet Elijah
defeated the prophets of Baal then she
loses oh I guess God was wrong no but
God God is never wrong
this is the sort of stuff even if they
don't say it that a lot of members of
Congress are thinking when they think
about how they are legislating now I
know many of you will write in and say
but you know David this it's really not
a big deal because you look at in Italy
everybody's Catholic you know although
elected officials are Catholic and it's
just no big deal it's really important
to understand that not all religions are
the same
and I know lots of Italian Catholics I
have many italian Catholic friends what
it means to them to be Catholic is a
very different thing than what it means
for evangelicals like I believe she's
Evangelical Lauren bobert to be
Evangelical and the comfort that folks
like bobert have even despite the
separation of church and state that
we're supposed to have saying things
like we need Christian nationalism we
need the church to be guiding government
and all of the things I've covered her
saying over recent Years A lot of people
with some connection to reality would be
embarrassed to be on video saying the
things that Lauren bobert says not not
for the religious reasons but because it
would be seen as so inappropriate to
come out and say I believe that my
religion not just religion but my
religion not anybody else's not any
other religions should be dictating how
government works you talk to Catholic
politicians in Italy who are nominally
Catholic and would consider themselves
religious in the way that many Europeans
do they would be human humiliated to be
caught saying things like what Lauren
bobert says so it's not all the same and
it's a really important thing to
understand this particular brand of
Christian nationalism that often comes
from born-again Christians and
evangelicals Etc
it's not just kind of wacky in terms of
the things they say it is but it's not
only that it also is extraordinarily
dangerous in terms of what it would mean
if they got their way and when you look
at what's happening in the Supreme Court
and Amy Coney Barrett and others who are
on that Court who at least to some
degree share a lot of these views you
realize that if things keep going the
direction that they've been going it's
not completely out of the question that
in some ways the bobert types could get
their way and that's a horrifying thing
to think about
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
because after all it's only January of
2023. we are not paying of much
attention to 2024 polling we're looking
at it sort of every three weeks every
four weeks I can't quite remember the
last time we looked at it but it is not
irrelevant and particularly when we are
asking the question is Trump's campaign
for the primary nomination imploding
before it even gets going when we are
not yet sure that Joe Biden is running
for re-election because despite what he
says he has not actually announced that
he is running for re-election at this
time or filed to run for re-election
there's a lot of question marks and
interesting things going on the
aftermath of the 2022 midterms Etc so
let's look at where the numbers are and
this morning there was a headline Trump
leads Biden in hypothetical 2024 matchup
according to a new poll that is indeed
true Emerson College has released a new
poll which finds that Trump is leading
Biden
44-41 however you do have 14 percent of
respondents who are not in either Camp
yet 10 say well I would support someone
else four percent were simply undecided
but I think the takeaway given that
Emerson is a pretty good pollster and
we'll see how good in a moment is that
it is very much not a foregone
conclusion that Trump can't win or that
Trump is certain to win and it is very
much not a foregone conclusion that Joe
Biden would have an easy time getting
reelected or that Joe Biden would be
unable to get himself reelected neither
it is a very very unclear scenario now
if we want to zoom out a little bit and
say okay but David that's one poll from
Emerson what if we look a little more
broadly I love that idea so then we
would go to 538's aggregation of
different polls and there you will find
the Emerson poll I just mentioned the
Emerson poll that's an A minus rated
pollster in a Biden DeSantis matchup
it's essentially even it's Biden plus
one and in that Biden Trump match-up as
I just told you Emerson has it Trump
plus three but what about other
pollsters well let's look morning
consult which is a b-rated poster has a
poll that's one day newer in Biden
versus DeSantis they have DeSantis ahead
whereas in Biden versus Trump they have
Biden ahead by three points all right
what about a different poll well we have
one from a few days ago this is a Harris
poll Harris is a b-plus rated pollster
in that poll Biden DeSantis has DeSantis
up three and Biden Trump has Trump up
five and then lastly and this is the
last one because then we'll get kind of
to our bigger observations yougov which
is a B plus rated pollster
Biden Trump has Biden up four
um and in a slightly different
formulation they have Biden up six
that's
um
registered voters versus what is a I
forget what a is not actual likely
anyway
um and then in Biden DeSantis they have
it even so what's the real takeaway here
the real takeaway is not no one of these
polls is really going to tell us
everything that we need to know the
takeaway is anything quite literally
could happen in 2024 we are not even
really in the primary season Donald
Trump did something that's sort of out
of not out of character for him but it's
out of norms historically to announce so
early that he is running he is scheduled
to start
um campaign events soon although I don't
know that they're going to be massive
rallies in fact he does have an event in
South Carolina this weekend our
correspondent Luke Beasley will be there
and we will have clips of interviews
with South Carolinian Trump supporters
for you on an upcoming program
um the takeaway is we don't have any
idea what could happen and so any
statements that sound like foregone
conclusions of the sort of Biden doesn't
have to worry or Biden has no chance
Trump's got this in the bag or Trump has
no chance none of those statements are
accurate at this point in time now what
about the Republican primary this is a
very interesting question because there
is a candidate who has not even
announced that he is running Ron
DeSantis who had some polling that
looked pretty good
more recently it doesn't look quite so
good for Ron DeSantis in a recent
morning consult poll Trump is leading
DeSantis by 19 in the primary in a
recent Emerson poll Trump is leading
descent despite 26. in a recent b-rated
big Village poll Trump is leading
DeSantis by 23 and in a recent Harris
poll Trump is leading DeSantis
um wait Trump Tim Scott Trump plus 50.
oh this is oh this is against other
people okay Trump is leading DeSantis by
10 in a Harris poll so even though there
was a period about a month ago or so
where Ron DeSantis was actually leading
Trump in a bunch of different polls
despite the fact that Trump has
announced and DeSantis has not which was
quite stunning it does not seem to be
the most common scenario right now
that's where we are Anything could
happen anything could change but we will
follow it probably like roughly every
three or four weeks talk Carlson is very
concerned about a floating space vagina
that is not a headline that I would have
guessed two days ago I was going to be
giving you today
this is the epitome of everything is
scary I'm going to explain right wing
fear-mongering to you with a segment in
which Fox News propaganda Tucker Carlson
is afraid of a Turkish floating space
vagina
um what am I talking about okay here's
the deal in Turkey there was a cloud
okay the cloud
to some people looked like a vagina
and some of you will say well David
really it's a vulva the vagina is inside
we all know what I'm talking about okay
we're using the colloquial term that is
usually used please OB gyns uh don't
write to me about this
it was really not like a huge deal it's
just a cloud I mean quite literally it's
a cloud but Tucker has to fear Monger so
he does a segment saying this is really
a problem this is not normal take a look
at this you may have seen pictures of
the very strangely shaped object that
appeared in the Skies over turkey yeah
what is that exactly it's not normal no
matter what they tell you
plus tomorrow uh millions of
church-going Christians in America still
vote for the Democrat yeah that he was
moving on to his next scary story that
there are Christians who vote for
Democrats maybe blame the vaccine would
be a takeaway all right so listen this
is it's so stupid but this is very very
instructive and I'll explain to you why
whether it's about big things or small
things the right relies on
fear-mongering tactics to gain support
and to push their agenda forward if
there's a specific person to blame even
better if there's a particular group to
blame absolutely fantastic it's a
strategy that fear creates a sense of
urgency we need to know what to do now
we need to know who is subjecting us to
this and on and on and on the space
vagina
he's using the same rhetoric he he uses
with a lot of this other stuff I don't
know that he's necessarily suggesting an
investigation he just seems confused by
it I guess in some sense but the way
that this works is you use the fear to
create the sense of urgency and to
otherize someone else to agitate people
to scare them to say well tell me what
to do please you've scared me now what
is it that I'm supposed to do and that's
the point you use the fear to get people
to take action without fully considering
the consequences and this is why
right-wing politicians will often use
fear to uh try to push for quick and
drastic changes to policies or laws guys
we don't have time to sit and think
about this and to debate it there's a
floating space vagina in Turkey we've
got to do something about it right now
now usually it's not a floating space
vagina it's immigrants or communism that
doesn't exist or Marxism that they don't
understand that isn't Marxism or
whatever the case may be but that's how
you slip changes through quickly that
aren't actually in the best interests of
the majority of people
fear can also be used to create Division
and distraction
from actual issues a floating space
vagina is not a real issue Tucker's one
hour show once you take commercials away
is probably 38 minutes or 42 if it's
like you know most corporate media shows
and every one of those minutes is going
to something
rather than something else and when you
do the space vagina thing you don't talk
about an actual issue that affects
people and lastly the fear is used to
create an US versus that mentality now
he didn't go in this direction
but the Turkish floating space vagina
could be used to make the audience
suspicious of what is it that turkey is
doing what is turkey up to exactly will
they have a floating penis soon or
whatever the case may be and it's part
of this distraction method and it fuels
all of these other techniques that I
talked about so it's such a silly
example it's a small example although
the cloud is quite large it's a small
example small scale example
of how everything leads to the exact
same rhetoric and tone and that's
another fascinating and sort of funny
thing whether Tucker is talking about a
potential nuclear war
or a floating space vagina his tone is
exactly the same which signals to people
who have this stuff spoon fed to them on
Fox news they should be reacting with
equal amounts of fear to both of the
things so it's quite sophisticated
propaganda and uh it would be better if
people were more prepared to uh defend
themselves against it we have a
voicemail number that number is 219 to
David P I recently did a segment on the
Pacman Finance Channel recommending what
I believe to be 10 or so personal
finance books that if everyone read you
would be ahead of 98 of the population
in terms of personal finance knowledge I
did that segment last week
someone wrote in I'm sorry they called
in and they said David what about Rich
Dad Poor Dad take a listen to this
David is Alan from Jersey I'm watching
your video on the Pacman Finance Channel
about yes uh Finance books you suggested
and your list did not include Rich Dad
Poor Dad by Robert Kiyosaki I can't
believe you left this one out I know
it's one of the best Finance books that
teaches you the difference between
thinking like a rich person versus
thinking like a poor person
for example poor person works hard pays
their taxes and gets screwed over when
their company lays them off but a rich
person like Kiyosaki writes a scam book
Ms Rich Dad forward ad scam book then he
gets in bed with Amway which is a scam
multi-level marketing thing yes and
forces and white people to buy his book
and that's part of his whole scheme uh
that made him the self-help Guru so yes
the Robert kiyosaki's main strategy for
getting rich is to write books and sell
them to people telling them it's going
to tell them how to get rich so if you
can emulate that that is that is a way
now listen I read Robert kiyosaki's Rich
Dad Poor Dad like the first couple of
books when I was probably 16 or 17 years
old and I don't find them substantive
and I don't find them serious now
whether he is a quote scammer or not I
will leave that to the critics to decide
but if you say to me David sir I need
recommendations for personal finance
books that are really personal finance
it's not Kiyosaki telling me to get get
just get start getting real estate that
will generate passive income uh and then
buy more of my books and maybe do some
Amway stuff no if you want my actual
list of good Finance book
recommendations go to davidpackman.com
recommendations and then we also have
the finance content at youtube.com
pacmanfinance I do not recommend Robert
kiyosaki's books or his courses or his
whatever it is that he is selling the
books I recommend are cheap they are
complete and that they aren't going to
try to sell you more stuff
um and again if you read these 10 or so
books that I recommend to you your
personal finance knowledge will be
greater than that of 98 of the adult
population I I've got nothing to sell
you they're not my books they're other
people's books uh youtube.com
pac-manfinance and davidpackman.com
recommendations on today's bonus show
the FDA wants to simplify the use in the
updating of covet vaccines what do they
want to do and who is already flipping
out about it I think you can probably
guess the first artificial
intelligence-powered robot lawyer is
going to represent a defendant in court
next month this is super interesting and
we're going to discuss it at length on
the bonus show and lastly the woke mob
oh wait no it's the right wing mob the
right wing mob has indefinitely paused
their m m spokes candies over right-wing
pressure
I thought we were the people who
canceled but they are doing a lot a lot
of canceling sign up at joinpakman.com
you'll get instant access to the bonus
show I will see you then